well Washington has proven again that
they are more afraid of change and pain
than they are the continued rising in
the American debt load 18 trillion
dollars and Counting and pretty much
both parties have decided to do the
ostrich thing we're gonna stick our head
in the sand and pass the bill because
we're more afraid this is what they're
basically saying they're more afraid of
a government shutdown and they're more
afraid of actually doing substantive
cuts and spending and your reaction to
those substantive cuts or your reaction
to a government shutdown is a political
nightmare for the political animal and
they're more afraid of you being mad
about those things than they are the 18
trillion dollars in debt and the
continued ridiculous obscene
out-of-control spending they do nothing
about it continually and so they adopt
the pasta the pot that they adopt the
posture of the ostrich to stick their
head in the sand you should always
remember a picture of an ostrich with
its head in the sand when they continue
to pass huge deficits which add to the
already huge debt and absolutely will
not address the fundamental issues of
overspending now what is the posture the
posture of an ostrich I don't know I
can't say that the posture of an ostrich
with its head in the sand well we know
it is its head stuck in the sand
but we also need know that that means it
stuck its butt up in the air and that's
what you people in Washington are doing
you're showing your butt and I got to
tell you we the people who have to
balance our checkbooks are sick of you
both of you
you're disgusting your lack of maturity
your lack of vision to look into the
coat front front instead you're just
worried about somebody worried about a
government shutdown you're more worried
that than anything you don't want your
party to be blamed for pain that is
coming because there's only one way to
cut a budget somebody's pissed it's only
one way and some of you are gonna be
pissed by the way it's your
grandmother's little program it's a
street that's being run through your
backyard it's something about you
hunting ducks it's something about your
little tree hugging the agenda is
something about something that you think
the government's supposed to be doing
that it's not going to be able to do
probably something that I wanted to do
that it's not going to be able to do
there are no budget cuts without pain
and these people are such freaking
children that they refuse to face pain
it just continues and continues when are
you folks going to vote them out of
office when are you gonna get enough and
send them home is there not any and is
there not enough of us left to actually
do critical thinking to where we
actually understand the kick in the can
down the road 18 trillion dollars worth
is eventually going to result in
economic suicide and when the debt load
think about this it's just like your
personal budget when your payments are
more than your income the chances of
reversing a debt repayment are reversing
your process and increasing your debt
repayment of just about going away at
that point you know we you and me have
to have what we have
collectively left and right old and
young black and white embrace pain
associated with the federal government
not giving us everything we want we're
going to have to embrace that pain
because you're going to have another
kind of pain eventually if you don't and
it's gonna be a pain that you can't fix
it's gonna get out of control I'm not
predicting the end of the world
I'm not an end-of-the-world guy but you
just have a math problem when your
payments are bigger than your income
you're bankrupt it's a math problem and
when you have 18 trillion dollars and
quarter they do they pass another 1.1
trillion with 3 hours left to go oh God
before the government shuts down to
which a whole lot of us would say good
well no you work for the government and
you don't like you want to say that and
I'm not trying to mess up your life
personally and I understand that there's
actually reality to that and I'm not but
I mean you know from a snarky standpoint
truthfully at the end of the day there's
a whole lotta government that's gonna
have to be shut down
and someday someone's gonna have to have
the vision on the backbone to say that
and do it and I just don't know if
they're electable anymore I don't know
if there's enough people that are mature
enough in our culture anymore so many
people want what they want their
government to do it's all about what
government can give me and they for some
reason forget that that has to be paid
for by someone somehow and it's paid for
with extra taxes coming out of those of
us that pay taxes pocket which now is
less than 50% of Americans actually pay
federal income tax that's scary or it
has to come out of borrowed money and we
continue to borrow the money and borrow
the money and raise the taxes but at
some point
your soak the rich plan doesn't work
because there's not enough money if you
took all of the money not just if you
had a hundred and ten percent Taxation
rate of the top five percent of
Americans in wealth you took all the
rich beats uber rich people's money
completely away from them you could run
the government for 14 days
so you idiots that think soak the rich
mathematical he's gonna fix this your
mathematical morons so that one doesn't
work hmm so increasing the income it's
not gonna work right busy Dave you
always talk about getting an extra job
why shouldn't we raise taxes and we
raise them about as far as we can we've
already crippled the economy because
we're taking so much out of the
producers pockets and sending it to the
government which is not a producer it's
a parasite I mean if you not realize the
federal government is a tick on the butt
of the American public it's a parasite
and guys let me just tell you if you're
a Democrat you don't get a pass on math
if you're a Republican you don't get a
pass on math math does not respect your
puppet your political ideology
mathematics does not give a rip about
what you think mathematics just works
every time oh man I think we've got a
bunch of adolescents running this
country
it's really disgusting it's really
depressing
think about it what scares me the most
is I don't know if you folks out there
have the backbone to vote them all out
of office every time everybody says send
them all home nobody does
they just keep sending the same morons
up there and you expect a different
result I guess we're the ones that are
insane out here aren't we chase this is
the Dave Ramsey show